The Legend of Zelda has a plethora of
hidden mechanics and concepts that are
useful to know as you explore it's
hostile yet mysterious world to increase
your chances of survival we've compiled
seven handy tips you might not know be
weary there are potential spoilers ahead
if you enjoy this video like it and
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more features on breath of the wild and
be sure to watch our previous videos on
all the things I wish I knew before I
started you can temporarily expand your
horse's stamina when you cook Endora
carrots into a dish it creates food that
temporarily increases your stamina but
you're not the only one who can benefit
from this tasty veggie give a raw one to
a horse and their stamina temporarily
increases by three your horse maintains
this stamina boost just as long as you
don't spur through it so don't push your
trusty steed too hard you can find
indoor carrots in the fair and
grasslands and Hyrule Ridge but you're
guaranteed to find some around melania
spring or by the trees that surround the
great fairy fountain in Kakariko village
treasure chest indicator there are
always hidden treasure chests to find in
the myriad shrines you visit if you're a
completionist the thought of not
uncovering all of them probably drives
you crazy thankfully the game has a way
of telling you when you've collected
everything in a shrine simply highlight
a shrine on the map and if it has a
treasure chest beside its name and that
means you've uncovered all of its secret
chests if it doesn't have this indicator
then you'd best go back and see what you
missed the Master Sword beam much like
past Zelda games breadth of the wilds
Master Sword also has a beam attack you
can use to fire at enemies from a
distance and as you'd expect you need to
be at full health to use it to use the
sword beam simply hold the R button to
aim the master sword and then release it
to fire a disc of energy the sword beam
is a useful Albia tweak attack that you
can spam quite often before the Master
Sword runs out of energy plus it's a
great way to hunt all those pesky
woodland critters
use the proper tools for the job
while you're out gathering essential
resources such as wood and ore from the
environment you might think that using
your weapons or bombs is the best way to
obtain them these are perfectly viable
techniques to gather resources but they
actually serve to your detriment to
optimize wood gathering use of wood
cutters axe it can chop down a tree in
two strikes and if you use a double axe
you can down a tree with a single swing
to find these weapons you need only
travel to any stable they'll likely be
hedged into a tree stump or leaning
against a wall if you're still using
bombs to break open rocks you've got to
change your ways after all I'm sure
you're frustrated when this constantly
happens to you there are tools available
that make gathering or way easier the
boulder breaker for instance can break
open rocks with a single heavy blow but
the drill shaft is far more efficient
requiring a single jab to break open
rocks quickly and easily you can find
both of these weapons lying around the
Eldon canyons you can get a Hylian
Shield the classic Hylian Shield appears
in breath of the wild and it's pretty
much the strongest shield in the game
[Music]
but where is it
Hyrule Castle oh man okay if you possess
the courage to go alone and are well
equipped with Hart's equipment and
weapons head to the southwest section of
the castle and look across the moat to
see a minecart rail use your cry Onis
rune to cross the moat and head into the
right tunnel follow it until you find a
minecart then hop in and use your stasis
room to propel the cart back where you
came falling the rails to the other
tunnel entrance continue through the
cave until you find this cracked wall
blow it up with a bomb
enter through the opening in its wake
and make a left to find a prison lock up
continue to the back until you see two
torches blow up the broken stone wall
between them you'll notice Elizabeth and
a mob limb but in order to open the cell
door to get to them you'll need to use
an arrow to shoot the switch through the
cell bars once you kill both of them
make a left and then a right into the
room filled with bones these bones then
assemble into a stall knocks mini-boss
defeated and the shield is yours
[Music]
it's important to note that if you
happen to lose or break the Hylian
Shield finish the from the ground up
side quest so you can buy it back from
grata in Tarrytown cooked hearty foods
offer full heart recovery and then some
if you're looking to minimize the grind
for health cook foods that have the word
Hardy in its name cooking these items
heal your hearts fully while adding a
fair number of temporary hearts to your
health a great place to farm for hearty
foods is the lush brownness forest in
the Ferren region which you can get to
if you head north
affarin tower the area's trees are
loaded with upwards of 15 hardy durians
this is a big deal since a cooked hearty
durian will heal you fully and grant you
in extra for hearts and if you cook
three that's 12 extra hearts and if you
get five we're talking 20 extra hearts
added to your health i'm telling you you
can't get more hearts anywhere else
consider bringing an axe to speed up the
process as it rains quite often in this
area making it hard to climb up trees
regardless once you've ransacked this
hot spot just come back after every
Blood Moon to find it restocked you can
mount a Lionel if you've completed the
zora portion of your main quest then
chances are you'll know about the
devastating power of Lionel's
these scents are like beings will stop
at nothing to eliminate you making
persistent use of both their melee
weapon and bow to cause you all sorts of
grief but it's possible to humiliate
these terrifying foes by stunning and
mounting them before you confront a line
although it's recommended that you grab
the stasis room upgrade from pura when
you're ready to fight one make sure to
maintain your distance you stasis when
it's about to charge at you once frozen
quickly shoot a bomb or fire arrow at
its head to stun it when it's down
quickly mount them and toss in a few
swipes at their neck
rinse and repeat this process until you
defeat it at times mounting a Lionel
doesn't seem worth it seeing as it's
possible to inflict the same amount of
damage when you're simply going toe to
toe with it but gosh is it fulfilling to
watch these jerks flail helplessly for
once in their lives what other cool and
useful mechanics have you found let us
know in the comments below and for more
coverage on the Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild be sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel
[Music]